well I just want to thank the organizers
very much particularly David and
instorage Schwartz as well as the
Ministry of Education and all the the
great the invitees for holding this last
panel on public health and medicine the
goal here is to answer two questions and
we can debate about the importance of
these questions after the presentations
but the first is with respect to public
health and medicine how to effectively
study Brazil as a field site so that's a
loaded question and then the second is
what impacts and challenges are there
for the exchange of this knowledge
developed between American and Brazilian
universities so we have a very nice
panel here of three Brazilians who are
invited two of which are professors here
in the United States and let's get
started by have introducing dr. Marcelo
della valle dietrich who is an assistant
professor of comparative medicine in
neurosciences Marcela had gotten his MD
and his PhD from Universidad a federal
do here garage Azul and he has now
established his research group and has
an academic position at Yale working in
neurosciences and particularly animal
behaviors and underlying mechanisms
thank you is this working
yeah so thank you very much for the
invitation I guess that was supposed to
be the moderator of this session and
then change kind of couple weeks ago I
believe I have very little to add to
these questions and I'm kind of an a
sort of an outlier in the sense that I
work with basic biomedical research so
showing that kind of research into this
group I think would be a little bit
boring so I prefer to to present sort of
an updated version of what I present in
the mean in the last meeting you made
about a small but energetic initiative
that I have in Brazil to foster
education in basic biomedical research
so I think it was nice to to be talking
here after the previous session because
I think some of those concepts are
important here but I think one aspect of
biomedical research is that the gap the
inequality gap is really huge because
it's a very expensive research to
perform and needs infrastructure
technology is under exponential growth
with all the computational resources and
the machinery that's now needed so it's
very hard to keep up with the growth of
the field in countries like Brazil if we
are not investing in science so but I
will give a little bit of my rationale
or if you or perhaps my dream the part
of my one of my life dreams here and so
the ration now it's very simple it says
so basically biomedical research
it's and since that's not only
biomedical research is it's dominated by
a system organizing hi hi hi Lee yo
article structure so there are few
people in subfields that they really
dominate science and by that I call
background background of some of the
scientists or the pedigree where they
come from who are their mentors you
really creates this massive power X
structure of the winner takes off so few
people they will be very well funded
they will have a lot of opportunities
and quite often they will drive
scientific discoveries because in
biomedical research the more resources
you have more capable you are of doing
discoveries so the hypothesis that I
work on this initiative is that giving
opportunity to talented individuals from
diverse cultural intellectual
backgrounds at very early stage of their
career could perhaps promote scientific
discoveries
different type of scientific discoveries
because now you are bringing different
different intellects to the biomedical
sciences by uncoupling this cycle a
famous scientist the founder of modern
neuroscience Santiago harmonic aha he
wrote a book which is called the advice
for young scientist and he said that
there is something very dangerous in
biomedical research that was 1889 which
is to come from a very famous professor
why's is dangerous because you are you
for the entire career you are gonna have
to work to sustain the theory of the
matter because that's the power
structure in the moment that you
uncouple that you are not going to have
the benefits of coming from that
powerful pedigree so basically you work
in your entire life to sustain the
theory of another not of your own self
so if you don't come from that kind of
pedigree you have one advantage you
don't have anything to defend so you can
breathe you have freedom to think but
then you don't have the infrastructure
or somebody to fight for you so that's
the paradox that caja raises at that
time a hundred thirty years ago the
importance of giving opportunity for
people that don't come from this
pedigrees because perhaps there are the
next really breakthroughs in scientific
discovery so I'm kind of inspired by
that what is the intervention my
observation is very simple I played
soccer seriously when I was twenty I was
14 then I broke every bone in my body
trying to play a competitive soccer and
where I come from in south of Brazil
there are two things that we are known
for some very good soccer players
Ronaldinho I play with together with him
and taught models extremely beautiful
women and it's amazing because I grew up
playing soccer in quiet bad areas I was
not poor I came from a wealthy family
but to play soccer have to play
everywhere every place that I played
there was somebody watching there was
always somebody watching
and they would come and talk to us to
provide some sort of reward for the good
players you could come here you could
get this they will contact you they will
contact your family they were always
these people watching and the same thing
happens in with the tot models they will
watch this 1213 years old girls and see
which ones are the ones with the
potential to be beautiful to be a top
model I've found that striking why can't
we do that with education why can't we
just look and see the talent see the
people that are motivated they can have
this capacity why can't we work on in
the children and in our teenagers or
young adults to give them the
opportunity to be leader so that's my
inspiration that's my observation and
perhaps one of my career dreams to apply
the same method to identify the next
generation of talented young scientists
in place there outside of the geographic
map map the determines current
scientific research mostly US Europe and
you know exponentially scale of China so
the goals of what I do which is a
substantial amount of my effort but it's
kind of my hobby is not part of my job
we want to say every time I spend an
hour on this I'm taking an hour away
from actually what pays my salary -
which is to get grants and deliver
science so it's a it's a it's a risky
decision but so my goals are to identify
the most talented young scientists in
basic biomedical research in Brazil and
if I could in the world but you have to
start somewhere I and provide
opportunity for them to receive
competitive training and perhaps as the
previous speaker john logan said that he
is starting 86 i believe perhaps in 40
years from now we can change a little
bit the landscape of biomedical research
and to create an environment of
scientific discussion and competitive
science in brazil because i think you
cannot just take people away you have to
go and and
make create some entropy in the
environment because I think that
agitates society and can create
awareness that's very important so
people can dream of that career not only
playing soccer will be a table model but
now becomes something interesting if you
are a kid that's new that role there are
role models out there we have to bring
that information to to to place and to
to automate facilitate the training of
talented brazilians abroad I don't think
that's that's bad I think that's a new
strategic plan because many of these
people will return to the country and
will bring now knowledge and these hubs
of network to create as networks of
excellence so we have a heavy experiment
doing experiments with this kind of
project for probably 10 years but when
you are too young nobody respects you
and so is - I'm relatively young but a
little older than it was 10 years ago so
people listen to me a little more than
before so our current so it's all brisk
brutal force when I'm gonna show here
it's trying different things and very
little resources a lot of my personal
resources actually so now we have a
player kind of a website we never we
want to make some sort of NGO type of
team but I never had the energy and the
funds to do it so we call opportunities
in biomedical research our we say that
we strive for excellence for Brazilians
and Latin American students so there are
three components the search for this
young people the resources that we can
provide and the education that we can
provide it's simple some things work
some things don't work and then with the
things that we don't work with drop and
we try again so it's basically doing
experiment with these kind of
initiatives in my field scientific
meetings are important so you cannot
work students and talented young people
with the P I so we have been doing
meetings
for almost 10 years the next one will be
next week and we call now seminars in
biomedical sciences so we usually we
invite junior faculty to go to Brazil
give talks we invite postdocs and grad
students because young Brazilians they
connect better with this kind of young
people and I select kind of informally
these people to go the ones that are
basically my friends and I trust they're
good people and I trust that they want
to give opportunity to whoever they
believe are good so I connect them and
many of them actually invited these
young people to join their lab in many
occasions fully funded by the host lab
so without need of scholarships or
anything like that so this year we have
150 registrations is our record so far
we start with 20 they went to 40 50 90
now it's 150 of this we have more than
120 students so I actually don't know
how to handle that many students we will
see I present a one-minute video that we
did a few years ago about one of these
meetings sa segundus college altitudinal
CEA's drama scholomance entrada new film
each ent Rizzo favor se entera Santi
millán terrazzo interpreters adores
internationals in asanas air nomads
yahuda Tzadik fasciae Sanaa Brazil value
degrade ozone illusionist Rollins dr.
Aden multiverses our watch is in the
interests and Chicano program I asked
Isadora's otras partes del conte are
communists concealed in each pesky
reminds me to the software programmer so
police throwing his grades of the sea
when vistas for the nomadic Mohawks
cheekathon pair to Episode on premium
aqua zoom loaded ice call anyway this is
just a short video that we made to try
to actually have some impact and
diffused is this meeting and so many of
these scientists are now probably more
than twenty truth is there's Network
they are now pursuing for PhD Germany UK
postdoc in labs in the best institutions
in the world so it's quite is actually
was it's quite an effective system if
you call that way to give opportunities
to people like that because it works so
the resources we have simple things are
blood wick resources because one thing
that people in Brazil they don't know
the opportunities sometimes just doesn't
reach them
so my be that there's a postdoc position
somewhere that they are qualified but
they don't know about that position so
we bring those advert that those
position those advertisement to them and
that actually facilitates a lot we also
have resource for them to learn how to
apply to grad school how to write an
essay and things like that and grant
opportunities so many of our undergrads
are now writing grants and they spend
summer in Europe the UK in Japan in
Australia things that are fully paid by
different institutions but they never
heard about it so now they can they can
understand that those opportunities
exist and so I also as an as an
experiment I thought that there were
some people that they should actually
have the opportunity so if you think
their knowledge of a soccer team you
cannot go find somebody and send to
Barcelona you actually need to incubate
these people for a little bit before
they are ready to go so we create a lab
I'd say I call an incubator incubator
it's the name is actually seed lab in
Brazil where we currently we have six
people there so they work in science I
do
to meetings every week with them using
Skype zoom and I try basically to
educate them and so they can get
opportunities to do science some of them
want to stay so they have the
opportunity to stay there too you know I
try to be basically an enzyme a
catalyzer of this process and they are
already publishing high-impact papers
that's important for our field they are
already winning competitive Awards they
are applying for international grants
something that they were never doing
before they never thought they were
capable of now they are writing their
grants they pursuing some of them for
PhD abroad and they are it's here so
basically that's kind of it's a small
impact for this but I think for me is
fulfilling so so far we have three
undergrads are pursuing training abroad
we have six grad students a year one
marks for one Kings College to InDesign
three postdocs at the a1 and UPenn and
one faculty went to UPenn for a
sabbatical that's kind of the result of
this initiative we also took about four
years of negotiation and but we also
were able of signing this agreement
which we call the copies
Yayo doctoral scholars program in the
biomedical sciences which is a full PhD
training at the AO in this program the
goal is to bring five to ten students a
year to Yale in the eleven different
fields of biomedical research pursue for
PhD the interesting team it is a win-win
situation copies is only spending a
third of they used to spend to train at
for PhD abroad now with this Agreement
they spend a third so we can Brazil can
send three times more students and with
actually with the training program
that's much better than any previous
training program and it's sustainable we
select people in Brazil based on the
cultural constraints of Brazil so now
they are not competing with
international candidates so we are not
biasing the selection for people that
are similar
so there was that are being selected
from the international pool now we are
getting people that are diverse because
they are being select against each other
and and they we take in account the
geography the the the different cultural
backgrounds and the continuous program
we hope and we hope to be of high impact
I just came back from Brazil with Tony
and Valentina there's two absolutely
amazing faculty with that have this
beautiful view of diversity and value in
different cultural backgrounds and
knowledge and we already select six
students and perhaps two more we are the
the two green stars are basically they
didn't fit exactly the biomedical
science program but we think that they
will fit in public health program and in
the ecology so we're trying to negotiate
to see if we can give opportunity to
them the only thing that I can say this
was an absolutely astonishing experience
with the three of us I'm very junior but
they are very senior Tony has
interviewed more than a thousand
students I think because he goes to
China every year in a similar program
where they select 20 Chinese scholars to
come to you and the students were
absolutely of extremely high quality it
was and if you look at their
applications the applications were not
that good actually
any international competition they will
be eliminated but once you interview the
depth of thinking of this students was
absolutely amazing so we are extremely
happy with this first class that's
coming this year summer 2019 so
basically that's it that's what I have
to say how how do we fund this it's
that's that's difficult and now all this
we have support from here and there just
not much the meeting that I organize in
Brazil in the beginning was basic
self-funded I found myself sometimes
even with my private resource because I
believed in the idea and then gradually
I could get a little money here a little
money there now the
yeah Office of International Affairs
they commit like some funds for three
years so we can run the meeting that's
really good so we can bring the a of
faculty and advertise actually our
program to Brazilian students and for
the Serra pelada Institute is a new
foundation in Brazil they was a
Endowment of the Moreira Salle's family
300 million reais
so they they have a operational budget
of about 15 million hires a year so they
are interested in investing in the next
generation of scientists across STEM
fields in Brazil so they are also giving
a little bit of support to us and this
year they bring some of their grantees
to give talks and interact so they so
that's kind of how we survive it's a
certainly these initiatives are in
danger because it's all the funds from
Brazil are drying out and if you like or
you know somebody that likes to help
doesn't need to be resources can be just
anybody that's interested in
volunteering you know contact me and
thank you that's it just to introduce
the sorry just to introduce the next
speaker so this is dr. Marcia Castro
who's a professor of demography and also
the chair of global health and
population at the th Chan School of
Public Health at Harvard University
Marcia has been very important several
major initiatives both globally as well
as in Brazil one is she's a founding
member the wit Wittgenstein center for
democracy and global health capital
scientific ed and global health capitals
scientific advisory board she has
actually applied geographical
information systems remote sensing
spatial statistics in a research across
many different size
in Tanzania in Ghana and also in the
Brazilian Amazon where she works with
malaria specifically and Massey also has
had a very large impact in terms of
education leading a Harvard School of
Public Health summer let's see I guess
it's a January program January course
almost the last ten years right eight
years ten years as part of the David
Rockefeller mapped American Studies
programs so Marcia please thank you so
first of all I want to thank the
Minister of Education for the invitation
to participate in this discussion about
the road ahead so I'm not going to use
slides I'm try to be very objective in
trying to answer the questions posed to
the panel in the very first thing I want
to mention is when we talk about public
health it's it slightly different
discussion because a lot of the work we
do involve samples biomarkers clinical
trials experimental treatments and there
is an additional level of complication
when we do that involving researchers
from different countries so I want to
mention um three things that go back to
the question how those studies should be
done effectively and then towards the
end I'm gonna mention only two challenge
there are many but I selected two so
point one is that if you really want to
do Public Health right you've got to get
out of the beautiful rooms of the Ivy
League nobody learns public health
understands public health or does public
health if you are not where the problem
is meaning in the field and I don't
think any doctoral students should be
able to touch their diploma if they
didn't go to the field to do their
dissertation and unfortunately we still
have some that have never been to the
field and yet they get their PhD degrees
it's not just being in the field but
it's understanding the culture because
culture
to determine perceptions of risk is
going to determine behaviors and if you
don't understand that you may come with
your own preconceptions and that means
your work most likely is going to be
used
useless and you can actually create harm
if you end up with conclusions that
don't really apply to the local culture
to the local context in that sense
another thing that is important is we
gotta be humble because you have the
best science you know you have the best
knowledge regarding science but the
locals have the best knowledge regarding
the context so you have to listen to
them you have to learn from them and I
want to quote here the one thing that
the current the new president of Harvard
mentioned which is we have to be quick
to understand the very slow to judge in
also connected to that first point is
that it relates to the history panel we
have to go back to history because in
public health the roots of a lot of the
problems that we are trying to address
now they are in history and if you don't
learn that we're going to end up doing
what we do all the time in public health
we make the same mistakes over and over
and over again and in malaria for
example that's one of the diseases I
work with you can read some papers from
55 and some from now 2018 and they tell
you the same problem it's just a few
years apart okay now connect it to this
first point in being where the problem
is there is something called
service-learning that schools of Public
Health should be the first ones and the
the ones doing it the most because it's
really putting the students and the
faculty on the ground doing your work
that benefits the community where
they're working I have to say Harvard is
really not doing that much or it's not
doing as much as it should but and there
is since last year the School of Public
Health is really starting to have a
major concern on service-learning
and I am very happy and very proud that
this course that we run
January that Albert mentioned it's a
three week program really intensive but
it's fuel based and and the idea is to
expose students and its students coming
from Harvard but also we students from
Brazil it's faculty from Harvard and
faculty from Pacific's
everything mixed it's exposing them
really to the good the bad and the ugly
on the ground in public health and one
one of the outcomes of this three-week
program is to come up with ideas that
addresses problems that they saw and on
the ground in some of those ideas have
been implemented by municipal health
secretary so there is there is sort of a
giving back which is the essence of
service-learning and a lot of the
students from Brazil are now pursuing
PhDs in theatres or two-year masters
abroad and a lot of the students from
Harvard went back to Brazil to do field
work over the summer in Rhodes thesis
papers dissertations on topics related
to Brazil and we had new collaboration
projects that started exactly because of
this exposure that's point one point two
is this was mentioned yesterday it's
it's all about how you establish
partnerships and what I would say here
is that there are partnerships and their
partnerships and in public health a
partnership really has to be a real
collaboration a two-way collaboration
that has deep connected to it the issue
of building capacity so those
partnerships really should be building a
bridge between the Brazilian University
the American University and through this
bridge you have exchange of knowledge
you have exchange of experiences
everybody has to win you have exchanges
of students faculty postdocs everything
and the reason I'm bringing this up is
that with the recent Zika outbreak we
saw ugly things
you know in people trying to go to
Brazil and do partnerships but the
partnerships were just giving your
samples and that's the last time you're
going to see me that's not a partnership
and I think to some extent Brazil gave a
really good lesson because the great
bulk of the knowledge on Zika was
produced locally Brazil had the
institution's
had the knowledge had the capacity to
actually do it in and I think to some
extent the this the worst in in those
crazy partnerships in research they
really come in emergencies
so I'm not going to go over giving
examples on Zika though there are many
but it became very clear how the nature
of this collaboration can be really ugly
in those situations the other thing is
those bridges should also support
institutional capacity so new diagnose
tests are improving a new machine in a
laboratory those are things that can
also be viewed and it's also a way to
build capacity
okay that's point to the third point is
the issue of translation
I cannot imagine doing any work in
public health if you can't think of how
to translate the results of your work
into some action on the ground there's
gotta be a policy implication there's
gotta be something coming out of your
work that can improve the lives of the
people on the ground all the communities
are working with if you can't figure out
anything you're not doing public health
I don't know what you're doing but
you're not doing public health depth
translation is absolutely crucial in to
that extent doing those partnerships
it's always important to involve people
from the government policymakers they
own the data they know the problems and
they're the ones to implement the
solutions if you involve them from the
beginning they also feel ownership of
that knowledge that has
generated and it's going to be much
easier to try to get them to implement
those solutions instead of just knocking
at the door and saying I did this great
work go ahead now and implement it
that's point three so let me talk about
two challenges and again there are many
more but I only selected those two the
first one is a challenge that comes
mostly from the way that schools of
Public Health and schools of medicine in
the u.s. work which is the nature of
soft money meaning faculty really have
to generate a large fraction of their
salary with grants
why is this a problem I cannot tell you
how many times I try to involve other
faculty at Harvard that an unbiased I'm
Brazilian so I want to make things
happen but trying to involve other
faculty at Harvard in the first question
that you ask is is there money to pay my
salary no okay
thanks but no thanks it happens all the
time so um what I'm trying to say here
is that it takes a little bit of
risk-taking of course it takes a little
bit of passion as well you really have
to like what you're doing it takes a
little bit of commitment with Brazil
again I'm completely bias a hyung
percent but those initiatives that start
without money
they are like planting a seed and weed
any seed some of them are going to give
beautiful trees some kind some of them
are going to die but you're never gonna
get the beautiful tree if you don't
plant the seed in the first place so
either you accept that there are some
risks and I mean now I have tenure but
million times people told me you
shouldn't do that and I probably would
tell a junior faculty not to do it I did
it but I guess it takes some kind of
personality and tough skin but if there
is an imbalance when you think about the
payment system when you want
the us in Brazil and the second problem
I want to mention is related it that
belongs both in Brazil in the US and
it's related to the sort of political
context that we live right now in in
both places which is the fact that there
is a lack of trust in science and then
it becomes really complicated to
navigate the news to navigate some
audience to navigate the government in
trying to convince that what you're
doing is really facts and it's really
good science if you take here in the
u.s. anybody in public health do it
climate change is in big trouble there
is no money and there's no trust I think
Brazil
I hope we're wrong but it looks like
Brazil is going towards the same
direction there was supposed to be a
climate conference in Brazil next year
it has been cancelled and I think the
incoming president to some extent give
signals that he also wants to get out of
the Paris agreement hopefully this is
not come true but um and so I mentioned
climate change in the US if you think
about the incoming president during the
campaign he mentioned I'm just gonna
mention one that we have problems with
maternal mortality in Brazil because we
may have bad oral health I don't know
where he read this but you know that's
the kind of things that can happen and
it really makes us rethink at us I mean
researchers and universities rethink how
are we gonna position ourselves how
we're going to position the results of
the work that we do in this kind of
context public engagement is absolutely
crucial engaging with audiences that we
are not used to it's it's a very
comfortable YouTube great research you
publish in a nice paper yeah you were
done well I think those times are pretty
much over and engaging with tough
audiences
putting yourself out there is more than
ever important so if we think about what
is the road ahead I think the road ahead
looks like the roads I have to go
through when I'm doing research in the
Amazon they're unpaved and pretty hard
to drive especially after the rainy
season but you know with a little bit of
persistence determination and in
encourage I think I think you can't do
it and those qualities I think are more
than ever in order thank you Thank You
Marcia and both you and Marcella raised
very important issues we'll get back
that to that in the discussion so coming
up quickly it's a real pleasure this is
a very special pleasure to to introduce
dr. Mehta Maya Hays who is not only a
collaborator but she a close friend in
compañero
for many years of working together so
dr. Miller Marv Hays is a researcher
senior researcher at the Oswaldo Cruz
foundation he's also an adjunct
professor full professor at the Yale
School of Public Health
mitr mara has had many leadership
positions at the is Valda Cruz
Foundation which is many of you know is
the research branch of the Brazilian
Ministry of Health there's a longtime
director of that Institute in in
Salvador Brazil he has had also
leadership positions at the San pick a
and actually was one of the generations
that have led to the really the success
of biomedical research particularly in
tropical diseases over the last 10 20 30
years he was one of those cohorts that
were trained in the United States in the
1980s and came back and assumed
leadership positions so Miramar it's a
pleasure to be here hey good afternoon
initially I want to say thank very much
to the organizers and also I'd like to
acknowledge all my colleagues that
instru my email as you can see send
email to everybody just to all my
friends
chorus from difference universe in
America and ask them to help those
questions and I will show you very
quickly move this line thank you
so the first person that I asked to
answer the question was Professor John
David it that was Albert and my my
Boston vac 19 it is 788 in at Harvard
and it's John David just mentioned that
one very important thing was the course
that masters has mentioned but as well
as a summation about opportunity that
were creating brings scientists from
Brazil especially from my state and
different state that went to the
Department of tropical Public Health and
all of them went back to Brazil and they
continue doing the research in
collaboration with the colleagues at the
Department of tropical private public
and he said also that use this
collaboration my case was really
important I think that agbot muscle that
helped me to build infrastructure in my
state and today my institutional has
collaboration
I can guarantee you with different
investigators in America Africa Asia in
Europe also it's in the mail to
Professor Lee Riley and prophesy Riley
actually initially he was at Cornell
when I invited him to come to Brazil and
professor Lee Riley when he came we give
him a visit a scholar to come to fiocruz
and that time I asked him to organize
across they organized this molecular
epidemiology course that was really bad
Albert called myself
Lee Riley several colleges from
America we offered this cause every year
at this cost now we had the last time
was this 17 edition and we are planned
to have the next one and during this
course we have opportunity to train not
all individuals that are the University
but as well as the people that work at
the mini sheriff of the health in Brazil
and during the course also bring people
from student from America from Europe
from Africa and from Asia that's really
a very unique experience and during this
course as much mrsa point out we had
opportunity to talk interactive student
that in the very end they come to us
they go back and establish the new
cooperation the early press was
Professor Mary use she was initially at
Harvard now she's problem and surfaces
universe and what she call attention
that she agree with Lee but what she
said here that she won't highlight the
ecstasy benefit from development of
network and opportunity for ongoing
collaboration
this is extent much longer than a
specific cost ravine
she said that I would also note that the
bidirectional nature of the interaction
this code can consume through
generations unity good the opportunity
for work across discipline also she call
attention that in Brazil has a very
impressive open database with health
demographic and order date that provides
one who access background for research
in the diverse of ecosystem population
socioeconomic start provide a rich
landscape for learn and research and
politician my institution but I can put
all this situation with you it's not all
if your crew is Professor Eric Cutrone
say that he's a grief everybody but he
call attention importance that for the
size of without born that allows a lot
of investigator from America they went
to Brazil like here professor all but
Cohen syrup individual from USA and also
this allows people to come to us a not
USA to everywhere
in the world and that was a real good
experience and we knew just to get a
good evaluation and see what can be done
in the future basic in the evaluation
that we had to have about this see SEF
professor well Joseph I think this
problem explain what several of the
individual mention here before said
listen we have a collaboration at
Cornell collaboration by year began 1964
still what's going on this collaboration
that means 54 years for example so
Albert was from Harvard but he went to
Brazil when he was at Cornell University
and he stayed there for 20 years and I
will show you some work that we did
together that made the difference for
our country and also could be applied in
different place and again he mentioned
that for example the only reason that
this happened because they had supported
they had phone from my own phone 1964 75
Rockefeller Foundation money from 74
1979 and the NIH from 79 goes to 2022
that means that's really part and this
collaboration involved almost 500
function that means a very impressive
number
professor Scott Weaver from from Texas
he did mention he has not terminal
collaboration Brazil but he just started
a collaboration for us and the project
involved a professor by Chico professor
a glam email that was our former student
and actually as he mentioned now
basically this is very important for us
not only to address the the challenge
that we have now virus disease no but
now I think that was mentioned before
now we face this our virus outbreak and
have this collaboration professor Scott
we were
real benefit for us and actually for the
people here since Zeke is not one a
problem Brazil but also became the
problem here in America as except
professor runner blood he was a little
bit said everybody said good things but
what we do what you need to do in order
to continue the recession where is this
obstacle he'll mention when he pata top
stock is the restriction place in both
direction on the full of information
material
he said protection is necessary but this
should be realistic balanced against the
risk in the u.s. the research are aimed
at preventing potential paths and
effects agent but what is this
substitute and yet
Asians are is not always clear in Brazil
the very street are for removal and use
of knowledge and biological materials
but the research are at times so broad
that add to significantly impaired work
by Brazilian scientists even with
individual without substantial protect
anything and here I did a sentence for
my colleagues in Brazil what they said
the same question then and what they
said I relished in relation to the first
question say our first we have a
population of over 200 million people
which are very diverse in cultural
socio-economic stats and helped service
access second our country has an immense
territory
with different environmental and weather
conditions such publish an environment
of very productive asset of health
problem some of them specific our
country but measure of them similar to
situation that can be observed globally
in additional scientist are very well
qualified and our resources fresh
structure is reasonable good compared to
other middle-income countries the most
effective approach to effectively
perform international stardom Brazil
need to integrate Brazilian research and
institutions image to produce high level
science improve a local laboratory
infrastructure and train energy research
both from Brazil and outside and it
relates to the second question said that
the most desire in fact our population
our production I'm sorry i production
out stents and chief technology that can
improve health not only of Brazil but
also of other populations and to train
people to work on help and incise
globulin some of the challenge are to
maintain and through partnership that
are Mutoh beneficial and plug the
bureaucratic bar for international work
with include experiment Brigitte
deportation biologic specimen shipment
here I will now present a case of two
sets the case of cassettes it's a will
connect to Professor Albert Kahn
professor Alberta Cole came to Brazil he
spent 20 years there and he was someone
that went to the hospital went to the
community he knew everything he knew
everybody in Brazil not only the
scientists about the people the street
knows Albert and Bob knows the people my
name and with Albert call leader this
project with several :
actually we came with this very clear
let's set this for in the relation one
disease that they will take eggs exam
for example Brazil leptospirosis was
tragic traditional because there a rule
occupational and recreational disease
publish an environment change associated
recent climate various led to the
emergence of human epidemiological
pattern you see this cartoon that was
very nice actually Albert and I went to
the polymer Islamic community and who
took the journalist that the guy didn't
want to go in the zip in the in the
Islam and the guy that time you had a
outbreak of dengue in Salvador and
Albert was in the hospital and but he
was decided because he was the hospital
he came to me said minam I have a
problem with leptospirosis peepees died
from lactose Brown said no but ok let do
the work and Albert was real excited and
in little this process then we took the
journalists to the field and he came
with this cartoon very nice car too
because that time it will try to
convince that we had not all
dengue but you had leptospirosis a lot
of individual worth died from lapis
from leptospirosis because they had a
misdiagnosis of tank and that I was very
nice in English let's say it's combined
half of the cereal I would take care of
the braces through that means the
mosquito Frank talked the rats and you
can see from the work that we did for
example now Burt came to me to convince
that leptospirosis was a problem
Salvador in Brazil I said how about the
number that have is law we had that time
in there only 120 cases per year just in
whole Brazil but wasn't it true the work
that we did with our car demonstrate
that instead of to have one 120 cases
per year we had 12,000 case and the
lethality is around 10% and as you can
see this leopard for us just to fit with
the centers that observe the
leptospirosis now is big probably the
big city you have a rain storm have a
lot of case in Porto Alegre Curitiba
some pol will generate better results of
a new Recife Bali and this also this
graphic here that was done in the first
work that Albert published in Lancet and
in continue doing that in our course
showed that if after rain if you had a
rain one week later if someone come if
fever headache muscle pain we should
think about the leptospirosis and rot
right now is more change because you
have to think about leptospirosis tank
super guna Zika and yellow fever deaths
come back and you see here were the
place that work in the panel in the is
the pas de Lima community see how is the
property and believe Baba didn't know
every space in this area here actually I
used to live in the Impala Lima when I
came to Salvador I come from a very poor
family and I had to live in the Islam's
again basing the work that we did
together and we knew that the epidemic
were associated ran for attack the same
slum community every year was a
breadboard transmission in a single
sharafa you know us we generated this
for me
that in Brazil have not only 100 cases
per year about 12,000 kids per year in a
case fatality going 10% but if the
individual pulmonary hemorrhage syndrome
this go over 70% and again because
Albert was in hospital then he came to
me minimize the people's died there and
we need to pressure the secretary of
state of health then you pressure them
listen will you take care of those in
you field then you press them to put a
mechanic ventilatory to help the people
and also to put a hammer provide
hemodialysis this made the difference
because if you don't provide those two
things the individual die in two days
but provide them a safe life and almost
finish orbit so they are the very
important thing from the work that we
did I just straightening or ties are in
the yellow we build the information that
we in beg give back this information to
the community and the community leader
and Paula Lehmann is learn they are able
to write a project and got 36 million
from Brazilian US dollars to build a
closed system in the periphery in that
specific area that's really something
very important again to do this work
will create a mount disciplinary team
with several review that you mention
here see the people and/or now is we
have people from America from from UK
and peep from different place work
together and I say I could guarantee you
that pub smoke more than 100 papers it's
443 paper here just for this
environmental but put you all together
and see I just put oh I forgot to say
that my old professors say that the work
that Albert did their leader with our
group that means the work that come from
this is learned to the morning and I
went to church to point out that way is
this graphic he will decrease the
prevalence of leptospirosis over door
because from the work that are done done
and talk to people in
we are able to generate the first the
breath test for leptospirosis that now
is available for the health system in
there
here now with Albert and our group now
we are really involved in is to face
this Zika epidemic and I don't go
through here but we were doing that
together and if several colleges see all
these people here are involved and for
us was a realtor I said the Zika
situation and I have a court now
following the latest that were supposed
to Zika but fault also the kids and I
receive money from the ni8 and someone
from Brazil from the state at the
federal level and here is just show this
picture here I can see how badly my self
is the top there and can see that we did
the science but was the science of
social inclusion because several
individuals the community became
scientists and some end of PhD level
that's really important scene and as you
can see we are basically up to now a 330
Brazilian trained 150 who has suited and
felt when were involved in project that
we are developed there no to face those
and here has like for shark showed that
we start let's say orange orange also
then they would leave Riley Albert Chico
you got a value Robert G Mira digger a
baker from you might Kindle and also
federic that were our student now he's a
leader this project that is really
important and I will just bring this I
got from my colleague early writing the
measure of to says are the number of
trainee who are now doing research
number of independent research grant
received by former trainee number of
trainee trained by former trainee number
former trainee now in position of
influence in health and biomedical
research number of publication number
public action initiative in Brazil as a
result of this program I could say also
not all publication but patent also and
here are some Leroy a orange also you
got a value is in the middle here say
dr. Akaka value over here is a leader
from our group there but I was just to
point out the importance that Alberta
Cole had for us
he really was a really important person
okay with this I said Chuck I can
probably say that about 50% of what
minimizer said was true so one thing I
didn't do was just introduce myself so
I'm of course Alberto and Don professor
at the Yale School Public Health the
Yale School of Medicine I'm also chair
of the Department of Archaeology of
microbial diseases at the School of
Public Health and had lived in Brazil
from 1995 to 2010 really you know in a
very unusual situation there was a
situation where as I was a professor at
Cornell but I was seconded to the
Brazilian Ministry of Health and that at
that time I think was a very visionary
move or investment not only from Cornell
University but from the Oswaldo Cruz
foundation I'll come back to that so I'm
just gonna take the liberty as the
moderator just make a several highlight
a couple of things before we get into a
debate and hopefully hopefully end my
comments with some provocation so that
we can get some especially we need some
provocation at the end of the day to
keep us awake so let me let me just say
one things and I'm gonna reinforce many
of the statements made not only during
my my you know Marcelo and Marcia in
Mitte Meyer who really showed you know
somebody very good or important examples
of success stories when it comes to
capacity building and training but I
just want to also say that there's a
really truly important value and these
were the Brazilian paradigm
for Public Health and biomedical
research in public and public health
research that have happened since when I
went to Brazil in 1995 and when we think
the advances made by really research in
academics in terms of HIV and universal
access immunization programs we have an
immunization program Brazil which is one
can make the point does things that we
cannot do here in the United States like
mass campaigns in vaccination coverage
rates which are much higher than the
United States
we took they had the session yesterday
on on the legal but I mean there was a
very unique Brazilian experience in
terms of the legal guarantee for social
rights which includes the universal
health care system and I think in and I
think it's quite obvious from us from
you know at least my own personal
experiences but I think the experiences
many people in the room is that what we
can learn or have learned in Brazil is
directly translatable in widely
applicable to settings where they're
undergoing either environmental changes
social inequity aging populations look
at urban eyes rapid urbanization and so
much of the things that have been
learned in Brazil and will be learned in
Brazil are going to be directly
applicable of what is going to happen in
the poorest regions or the poor regions
in South Asia or Africa and so I think
that's the important part
I think the second issue is is that I
think the other thing is in an American
who has been working in Brazil and
started in 1995 he's really been
impressed by the aspirations or
Brazilian researchers I mean I remember
the the morale of Brazil researchers you
know in 1995 that the beginning of adavi
when the crippling inflation the
crippling social inequity that was
happening and and you you talked to
Brazilian researchers now and I think
the success stories master raised an
important was the Zika that was led by
Brazilian and Brazilian researchers
Brazilians are leading global
initiatives on the social determinants
of health you know it has made an impact
in terms of the dialogue of south to
south translation whether it's back
scene and vaccine development with
Butantan and Bill Mann games or whether
it's training in capacity when we think
about you know Mozambique and Angola and
I think one of the best indications of
those aspirations in the realization of
those aspirations or the US students I
mean I think we've had I mean much of
the Brazilian studies and I think Marcia
and Marcelo can can attest to this you
know much of the excitement about Brazil
is not to necessarily but and of course
it's working in the field but it's
really to learn those those paradigms
that are unique to Brazil and much of
those things they're driven not by us by
the faculty but have been driven driven
by the students now I'm going to go su
to the provocation and with all those
good things that have come out I think
we kind of my vision is that of that of
the cup half half-empty
we have then the cup you know half full
we all had the kind of this sense I
think perhaps that's why we're sitting
here in the room that we can do more
with what what we have with the
expertise that we have in Brazil of
course but between Brazilian in the US
and that we we're not we haven't been
responsive to either the aspirations of
Brazilian researchers but also
aspirations of our students whether
they're in Brazil us and I think many of
us in I think the earlier session had a
speaker who has expertise in in China we
see the kind of negotiations in the kind
of the infrastructure in the structure
that's being built with our universities
in China and you kind of scratch our
heads and say why aren't we doing this
in Brazil why are we doing the same
paradigms on our relate you know that
we've done 20 30 years ago we're not
thinking out of the box and I'll just in
and I think we really feel many of us I
feel sad and I'm looking at Don filer
you know in the back but we're just kind
of not building the robust programs out
of the box exciting innovative programs
that we're seeing being done in other
parts of the world I think part of those
reasons we're highlighted I'm gonna
bring this together some of the talks
before but dr. Fischer told us and a lot
of this is the ambiguity the undefined
role of us in
in institutions as Brazil is growing I
think there and I would put the blame or
not not the blame but to be provocative
I think the blame has to be assumed in
Brazil the lack of strategic vision you
know many of us many of these programs
are one-on-one organic collaborations
but they are highly fragmented I had a
very nice conversation with dr. Simonton
Lal last night you know they where
should that investment be strategically
should it be application or should it be
basic you know
there's we have a very fragmented we
don't have a unified vision of that you
know we have let's see the you know
we're losing out especially when we
think of biomedical research and we're
thinking of Public Health we're losing
out on really the impact of
collaborative research there was a
discussion last time but for us it's
extremely important the account is shoes
of economy of scale in critical mass in
terms in these are these are issues that
Marcela raised earlier and I can't say
how important those are and then lastly
I think and this is what Marcia said is
we do not have the business model to
make long-term sustained impacts one
yeah I think she said was more on the US
side was the soft money position but I
this is my own personal opinion but I
feel that we are losing traction at
least between US and Brazilian when we
compare to the more robust programs the
Newton initiative in in the UK or the
initiatives by dif adore the welcome or
in in Germany and I think we're and
that's part of this we've been
entrenched I think in paradigms and I
think this is the right time to to make
new paradigms I don't have the answer to
what those paradigms are I mean I think
I had a very nice discussion with
doctors is Timothy Allen what that could
be
but I'm gonna use that to open it up
that we have successes but I do think
that we have a sense that we're not
doing what we should be doing and that
the that the some is is is lower than
the some of what we're all are is not as
is what is the expression is not as the
hole is not as
is is not greater than the sum of the
parts so let me stop there and open it
up to questions both from the you know
responses or questions from the from the
the panel in the audience thank you very
much to all of you can you hear me yes
good very impressed with this panel with
the highlight of both the impacts and
the challenges of doing this kind of
collaborative work with Brazil has many
parallels with my work in Argentina and
one comment / question for you is that I
became I became increasingly
disappointed with global health
initiatives in the United States because
they tend to take a very ethnocentric
approach when we take students down to
Brazil or Argentina we are not teaching
them to learn from the community Marcia
was very clear on that the experts are
down there in the context and what works
and I'm very skeptical about so top-down
approaches to public health and global
health so what is your experience
regarding global health initiatives from
the states that they're now every major
university has a global health program
and I see that is not having the kind of
success that we expect and I wonder
whether it is because it's always
top-down always savior complex going
underline all the programs in that
I don't think it's always bad but
they're really bad examples the course I
teach in general there are other for
what they call field trip courses and
some of them are horrible honestly I
think they should stop because they have
very little interaction with the locals
and it has a you know a touch of this
kind of tourism that you go oh look poor
people yeah which really annoys me a lot
you know it's like those tourism in
favelas in Rio I'm from Rio that really
knocked my socks off and honestly so um
but there are good things happening I
think the the good experience is Oh
first of all what is global health right
global health is one of those sexy terms
that suddenly everybody wanted a global
health and in you take people from ten
different global health centers and you
ask them to define you're gonna get ten
definitions and probably none of them
really should get the essence of what
global health should be we have other of
those terms right resilient health
systems good lord I mean you're
basically talking about the same thing
we'll be talking for 100 years you just
give us you know a catchy name
so um I think there are good examples
and the best ones really are the ones
that engage with the local community and
give something back if you don't give
anything back it's tourism it's really
not global health you know to do the
right thing you need the right people
and not everybody leading those courses
have the commitment to make it happen
we're human so yeah and let me just add
one quick thing was I in my notes I had
forgotten
Stuart here's to a Schwartz yes okay so
so I think this is you know very much
grounded in in perceptions of the other
and in
think that's what you're referring to
and that the in the ethnocentric I think
there did two things in and again a
close friend of mine and classmate is
Paul farm and I think this is really the
question about who's the hero you know
and and I think what you're reacting to
is you know the you know Americans going
down that paradigm Americans going down
and being the hero in in such a clad Lee
that paradigm is gone I think I mean
healthfully I think at least in the
school School of Public Health
crews well let me at least I'm not sure
about the United States side but at
least in Brazil there's there's in it
and I think middle Meyer you know you
know very eloquently you know show the
alternatives and many programs training
programs are there but let me go back to
Stewart's part and I think the other
part is is that I mean I agree 100% with
Marcia she's the chair of global health
in January well you will be so you know
and I'm part you know in this is every
you know people have drunk the kool-aid
right you know it's you know we we're
calling something new of what existed
you know for for many years it's sort of
like the Emperor's clothes but but I
think what it really comes down to is
going back in this was I think the
discussion I think the first session of
today is is that you know we have to
prepare the students you know you know
for these experiences as a part of an
education and I think one critical one
and I'm gonna say a defect here at Yale
which I believe is in many places is
that language okay how are you going to
interact with a local community how are
you going to if you're gonna have only
short-term training experiences and the
students don't learn in Portuguese we
have a rule that all our students have
to learn Portuguese but when we go to
our Spanish and Portuguese Department
there are no courses that they can take
and so I think this goes back to just go
back to the point that was made earlier
this morning those programs are
essential not just for the people the
scholars in Spanish and in in Portuguese
but for the for the medical students for
the medical doctors for the
public health officials for the
engineers for the environmental things
in that so the Kuna that we haven't
filled that goes back to some of the
structural defects that that we talked
about before
go ahead so I think there is this
imbalance of power to some extent that
links to the problem you mentioned and
unfortunately in public health we have
way too many examples of you know people
going to another place and ignoring
everything and trying to do something
that they believe is really good right
and we don't have to go that way back
you know in time last week big debate
because a group of researchers wanted to
release genetic modified mosquitoes in
burkina faso
for malaria they never consulted the
local population people are not aware of
the consequence of that in fact not even
the researcher know what's going to be
the consequence of that it's a huge
problem right now but well you have to
understand the side of the government
any money that comes they want to take
it and this is it this is a huge problem
so so it's not just two researchers
you also have particularly when you have
this imbalance of power when you talk
about Disease Control some governments
will take any money even if that money
is not going to be allocated to do what
needs to be done to reduce the bird so
let me just say part of that response or
the solution is is marcelo in my cell
this program and you know i think please
comment on this i just want to say that
i think i i'm i don't have much
experience with too many places in the
world or in brazil but it's one of the
places that i have been or interact with
people there has the highest level of
lack of vision
that's brazil brazilian universities in
brazilian leaders most of them just lack
of vision they are there for two years
or four years to build some power
structure some empire and they believe
that that's interesting and so sad and
it's also i think combined with
tremendous incompetence
of political leaders and many people are
in power positions they are just not
prepared for leadership positions or
they don't have management skills and I
think I believe it listening my field in
this micro world that I live in my very
small experience it's very hard you try
over and over until somebody that has a
little bit of a vision is in there and
then you have to stick to that and then
you make something and you make a move
and that move needs to be something that
the next ones that will come cannot just
take it away because if they do it is
going to be ugly for them so I think
this lack of vision dislike this and
it's what dominates this you know we
don't have investments the investments
are scattered when they happen they are
in one initiative that's not sustained
so that also it's a so I think I believe
that's a big problem with the the way
Brazil is organized as a country and as
a political entity it's just my vision
yes thank you thanks so much for a great
talks it's a question for dr. dietrich
your idea of incubator is fascinating I
find and I like your analogy with soccer
football team I think it's it's very
apropos could you walk us through what
you were doing as far as the incubator
is concerned the lab if any and given
your limited resources how are you
managing and what what outcomes have you
arrived at so far again I mean these are
very relatively small initiatives
compared to what they have shown here
but you know I'm talking about what
happens they're not people that we find
we incubate and now they get training
elsewhere we have like a postdoc there
an undergrad there that came from kind
of that incubator but the kind of
research that I do is sort of expensive
but you if you are creative you can be
cheap so I I recognize that one cheap
things computer you buy a $10,000
computer that lasts forever and so
that's one component of it with poor
computers we train people in
bioinformatics computer science and it's
a small group but one of those students
is now here so she can get a better
environment to grow perhaps go back or
not but then we also it's easier to
Train
I brought virtually computer scientists
and then in the hostel there they have
very good infrastructure is actually
quite equivalent in terms of I do any
more work equivalent to the animal work
that we do here Yale but one of the
problems with Yale it's that it's is
it's virtually impossible to use some
animal models just too expensive it's I
cannot afford for example because it's
it's outrageous there is no a cleaner
calculation of costs is just as the soft
money type of thing that we have to pay
yourself but they also overcharge
animals without clear indication where
the charge comes from so for example I
collaborate with China they are doing
all this CRISPR animals they I do CRISPR
pigs in China we cannot bring pigs to
the United States we do CRISPR they're
doing CRISPR guinea pigs in China I
cannot bring to the United States
they're doing CRISPR rats for us they
already did forty some rat we cannot
bring to the United States because I
cannot afford the cost and there is no
infrastructure to generate that money I
send them to Brazil so I have made
agreements with Brazil all these animals
are going to Brazil I have a postdoc she
graduating Oxford she's actually going
to Brazil for six months experience
because now we have surgeons that can do
interventions in animals that actually
the best labs in the United States
cannot do properly but they can do it
because they have the technical skills
and the motivation so they train these
people and so we have this in a micro
level there are opportunities that are
not that
expensive is just too much work and with
a lack of you know I think Albert's say
it's a fragmented experience is not at
the institutional level there is no
support so it's kind of sometimes I feel
like you are battling against an army
and you were just the only one so that's
kind of difficult but it's possible my
goal is just just to serve as an example
and perhaps one day that example can be
disseminated perhaps in initiatives like
GAO has campuses in asia why not having
a campus in Brazil you know why not
having all this talent from that Latin
America and so I think that you have to
bring the examples perhaps sometime one
day somebody will see that and that we
can expand that initiative I just like
to add two points to it Marcelo said one
point is the the you know much of this I
think is not any short person there at
the personal level this is a
structurally many of these are
strategies and this goes back to the
comment I think made by Dane Boras about
the the the difficulty in many depending
on the field of intermediate structures
in the empowerment or you know in Britta
that capacity building that really needs
to be be done in that I'm just
reflecting on that I think this the
second point is is that you know we
really haven't with Brazil we haven't
thought out of the box you have done it
Marcelo we have done it to some degree
but we have joint professors right we
have professors who are both professors
in the Brazilian University as well as
United States but it's never we don't
really have a robust you know what
business model or how say it find it as
such as they have in China where
professors are truly co-financed that
belong to both ones you know I think
that that's something we're gonna have
to if we really want to make you know to
integrate or to we're gonna have to
build those types of business models and
and I'm not sure how we're gonna do that
but and who would support that but
any other questions
what is happening to the incidence of
chronic disease in Brazil you know over
the last let's say a few decades in a
long war but the ratio of health care
costs to GDP again over the last decade
or two the reason why I ask is I've
heard a theory that all these things
have become a problem because of the
exponential growth of some of these farm
chemicals which are really becoming a
huge problem in the opinion of some
people so Brazil has a universal health
system and they have a special program
for primary care that has really good
coverage and has made a huge difference
in reducing avoidable hospitalizations
reducing mortality and they also created
a special drug program that provides
medicines free of charge
particularly for asthma diabetes
hypertension so so it's actually not
getting worse yet that's the key word
because this program that provides drugs
has been largely reduced the program for
primary care suffered a major cut in
coverage because Cuban doctors who are
helping to expand the coverage to areas
where Brazilians don't want to go are
now leaving the country and when you
harm primary care then you're going to
have an impact in those diseases and if
people cannot have access to primary
care into the drugs then and you know
it's it's not gonna be as immediate as
infectious diseases that those are
chronic diseases but most likely if
nothing changes it's gonna get worse
but for now for the past ten years not
bad at all
meet my would you like to comment some
way I think that the current disease are
increase also intimated I'll quiz in
this consequence of the demographic
transition and also because you are
improving the life expectance I think
that this all the scientists are now in
the a little bit world because we have a
situation that right increase a little
bit the coronary disease but in the big
cities where increase the infectious
disease and since we have also violence
together this will be a big challenge
for us in the future but I agree with
the program the Zeus unified system of
the help of Brazil and did a very good
work and I hope that can continue that
because this I'm sure that helped not
the promise you to grow exponentially
let me just say that I think middle
Mario raises an important point you know
the costs are going to explode because
of the aging Brazil is rapidly aging and
so you know there is a threat and that
is a major issue and there's been major
policy positions done in the last five
years because in the next 20 years I
think the population above 6 years of
age will will triple sure of course
that's good and I think and I think most
of us would think that it's probably not
the environmental exposure to pesticides
that are causing this increase in
chronic diseases but it's just
Democratic is this epidemiological
transition that's that's happening I
think that's it any other questions or
comments that people would like to make
let me just ask the panel one thing so
what's the road head what should we do
which we need to do I mean what what do
we just very objectively what do what
needs to be built or done after we leave
this meeting today
in my husband my hope in my compare
which beaver pragma in my case I think
that have a lot of challenge I think
that for example the problem megacities
that's top should define priorities one
is probably to address the question of
Mecca series the second one is probably
if you have to be very specific is a
drug resistant a lot about control
resistance and the other one is kisser
since I mentioned that we have a very
important let's say Asia transition in
cancer now became really a big problem
and especially the case of connected to
infectious disease cancer connection
virus and bacteria stuff like that to be
very specific so we have a new
administration entering January first we
have a new administration
masya based on what you know what should
what should you what would you want to
tell them to do and what should it what
should be done in order to to both from
the research and academic public health
okay so as I mentioned before I mean the
road is gonna be bumpy but I think what
we need is we need to get people that
are determined that are persistent they
have passion passion is absolutely
crucial he you wouldn't be doing this if
you're not passionate about what you're
doing and people that are really willing
to put their faces out there and and you
know be slapped sometimes dealing with
tough audiences the government being the
first one so I guess it's it's gonna be
really a rough road but we have to be
prepared you know have a tough stomach
and deal with the problem put in the
best science we can and doing the best
public engagement we can it ain't easy
and we're not used to do it but we're
gonna have to learn it the hard way just
one quick thing is that it's not that
easy to teach passion right
you know it's not like it's not like
you're gonna go to this possible to find
their own passion you're not gonna go to
a football field and you're not a lot of
football fields of scientists everyone
has a passion might not be the same
passion that we have but if we help them
to find their own they can make their
contribution if their passion is just
some bad of some bad thing for society
then we have to take care of it but I
think the road I had in my little world
I think the first thing there are good
examples so I think if I was somebody
that science prevails so I would map map
what's going on you know generate data
what are the good examples what are the
bad examples learn from them and invest
on them and and in try you know without
taking risks nothing happens and I think
my other thing is you know if you want
to build excellence in my field
biomedical research in Brazil you need
investment okay you cannot invent if the
universe is I mentioned before they have
this bureaucratic an empowered system
then it's nice you cannot apply the same
system that you do with Asia you cannot
create a campus there because not going
to happen
or is it happens it might be destroyed
in five years so that's good because we
have to be creative we have to generate
a new system in that system can be
applied i was mentioned to people from
the minister yesterday i sincerely
believed in one system and when the
investigator becomes a commodity i used
the word commodity so the you know
american universities they have that
possibility so if you create a system
and now a scientist comes to brazil but
he or she comes with their own package
and they can pick whatever they are
gonna work and they have a network of
support from an American University for
example let's say a Yale Brezina scholar
that goes there for six years position
that's renewable for another six years
so this money now I go with my package
and say a USP are you gonna give me the
infrastructure no okay I go somewhere
else so now I'm a commodity and now the
university needs to adapt so you use
innovation to make the system
being bureaucratic and be more efficient
so we can but would that work who knows
but if you don't try and it's not that
expensive for the government you know
the budget that we're talking about it's
a few million dollars that's nothing
and it's Brazil the rich counter so they
can make those those those risky moves
but they you need people that are
interested in thinking about the future
they have a vision without vision
nothing happens so I think you know I
think debating about those things will
be helpful and I think the American
University can contribute so much they
are contributing Asia they can do in in
there in in Brazil in Latin America but
they might have to use it slightly
different strategy because it's not
going to be something that's going to
work there because the lack of vision
let me just end with I think a very
important thing that you said in the
beginning is is that you know we just
goes back I think it's gone through the
country we don't really look back we
don't look back at history and you know
why don't we apply the quantitative
methods that we use in our research why
don't we apply it to implementation
successful academic or programs in it I
think Marcel you said it let's get some
information let's look at the lessons
learned but I think we should do that
quantitative so if there is a
recommender I would have two copies or
Minister instead of the edge got some is
that you know you know do that analysis
you know what because a lot of our
experiences that we heard today these
are anecdotal experiences but I think we
need to have you know a bit better data
to go of it so with that I think we are
three minutes over time thank you very
much everybody
you